[Music]
well I like the Bamba did
there's no visibility pilot the
Bombardier there's no visibility
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
what are you gonna do what are you gonna
do when they come for you enzyme these
[ __ ] don't know but in his life
you gotta answer for everything once I
figured that out it was all over but the
shopping
[Music]
you
[Music]
are you kidding me or what uncle Joey
here Tuesday night reporting to you from
the [ __ ] balcony of debt for any oog
is back I got an a to that I got an 8
the wedding cake I got a couple [ __ ]
cheapos along disclose different breezes
for the mind and guess what swinging
they can give it our bubblegum and as
usual that's not we do it just because
it's Tuesday night no no but I throw you
off we call 24/7 seven days a week
reefer edibles and whatever else bumps
into the [ __ ] office of doom
it was a beautiful day to be alive the
birds were chirping everything you'll
enjoy wait I was busy today I was making
fun of moose I didn't think we stay
alive my foot and [ __ ] you got stuck
in this smoking dope that's one of my
pet fun pastimes but besides that I
gotta get down and get there you and I
roll up my sleeves and let these
[ __ ] know there's a new
[ __ ] town
[Music]
then I'll have to wit [ __ ] glasses to
look intellectual and I have a tattoo or
gotiya but winter hat on and maybe I'm
all [ __ ] secretive I'm a bad
[ __ ] from across the street
young saying I don't stop to the [ __ ]
last cannon goes off that's how we do it
[ __ ] and I hope that's how you're
[ __ ] doing it but enough with the
chitty-chat over Joey let's spot this
[ __ ] you know what you're
absolutely right I wish you could smell
but Uncle Joe is blowing you
[ __ ] right now you know and
believe that that bomb it yesterday
all the reefer professionals on the
Internet he didn't even clean the bubble
you know what was smoking here you're
smoking that Canadian [ __ ] coming down
from the mountains and you're paying too
much you know I'm smoking in California
that you know the word on the street
don't smoke on a Joey's weed if people
would just grow weed farm for Joe but
and I flipped the history of THC or
whatnot
[Music]
smooth brother hmm when those feels
great a couple what [ __ ] smash this
place look for a wall but I'm saving
those for breakfast you example named
I'm like a good what's not to get that
[ __ ] go on a second clamp hold
on to what the [ __ ] that I just eat
[Music]
that's it that's that unless you offer
me I won't I look a long way one looking
the other and the guy in the middle of
saying what do you want from me that's
what life is about for me I'm just a fat
[ __ ] felon trying to smoke dope with
you [ __ ] and get high talk
about the day's events maybe if we get
to that if not we just don't like the
reef over here that's it I might have to
cover the man so what's going on with
speech I don't give a [ __ ] but less my
got popped for different [ __ ] instead
look when I heard he was put on to up to
I didn't give a [ __ ] my dudes a bum then
now he's a bum now just like Tony
Montana's mother said Brock glass the
hall that he needs is somebody bigger
than him and also he gets bronchitis in
his stomach he they have no problems in
his stomach when he was equals [ __ ]
steroids did he we're gonna eat more -
what happened he saw a black dude that
was bigger than him he tapped out he
held onto his stomach
all of a sudden he wants to come back he
gets a little [ __ ] more country and
[ __ ] dummy see you fell for the fight
of the year was out for his [ __ ]
what's his man and the [ __ ] score
[Music]
the reason we brought lessons brought
lessons cuz always been the biggest dude
in the room and he would fake
wrestling's for a [ __ ] living fake
[ __ ] lessons he came into the u.s. he
surely should be big beating them guys
look at the [ __ ] size him but when
somebody looks him in the eye stands up
to him game over
trust me I went to prison and all about
the psychological the [ __ ] cars and
dude give me one little white skinny
dude we don't give a [ __ ] one of those
Irish dudes hate in the head with a
chair
that dude goes the way that goes to
power don't want shaking people down for
white bread it's over I've seen it a
thousand times in my life it just always
been the biggest dude at the party so
nobody says nothing and they stand there
all irrelevant you don't go to Compton
the body's [ __ ] now cuz they don't
give a [ __ ] when I was in [ __ ]
[Music]
shame shame on you it's a fake might do
fake fake white dude made up muscles
brother he that subtle moment is
stunning you know they'll have nothing
wrong become [ __ ] gorilla biscuits
you guys are so easily quantitive breath
I said the problem is in America today
that what attacked with a knife and a
[ __ ] the steroid you guys like huh
I've seen skinny guys missing an eye
that'll [ __ ] those [ __ ] up they
don't give a [ __ ] jack
they'll kill Bobby but you guys fall for
that [ __ ] me I know what the [ __ ]
guys on the dark alleys
oh look at that [ __ ] right there
you know we do it dog I'm stone to the
gills already I'm just working off the
[ __ ] fuels and muscle reflex right
now but not at your [ __ ] up same way
here a couple shows tonight the Howell
ray Tatom and I'm like respond 11 we'll
be smoking dope there too so if you
ain't doing nothing show up come on out
we got a podcast a couple meetings in
the daytime I don't know if you'll see
me come on a day but at one point or
another
you don't smoke a bowl with you guys
just to let you know it ain't over till
the fat lady [ __ ] sector
and then over to the fat lady sings but
you always never think that ladies in
the [ __ ] clock with one foot oh she's
warming up right now [ __ ] that's the
way I always been so [ __ ] you always
gotta be able to [ __ ] defense waiting
for these [ __ ] epistemic anyway
as you could talents come to the [ __ ]
gills
I love you [ __ ] have a great
night
don't forget about me in the realm I'll
see you guys tomorrow same bat-time same
bat-channel below and deep them alright
you know us swinging from the [ __ ]
fences here swinging for the fences I'm
sorry I love you got suckered stay black
boy it didn't get my mind till I beat up
ol dipper get my a liar Stabler